make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are picking up with the flash
year one which is really like Joshua
Williamson kind of reworking the Barry
Allen mythos kind of unto himself it's
in the nature of comics that things
change so this is actually kind of cool
because it's really like a more in-depth
origin of Barry and what this does is it
basically picks up initially with him
kind of in his attic reading his old
comics now for those people who are keen
on who know the history of Barry there's
a lot of small little nuances and easter
eggs in this story that really kind of
add to the to the greater whole right
cuz like the average reader would look
at this and they would say okay so like
Barry's reading comics and they would
just kind of write it off and call it a
day but if you go back and you look at
the old Silver Age stories when Barry
Allen first showed up DC showcase number
four you go look at those old stories
Barry Allen was inspired to become a
superhero by reading the stories of
superheroes namely the flash Jay Garrick
because on earth one where Barry at
Barry Allen's from the flash Jay Garrick
who hails from Earth two is a fictional
character now DC found ways to kind of
write that in write to say like well you
know the like you know his dreams and so
on and so forth and whatever but the
overall gist of this is that Barry Allen
is basically as a kid reading the
stories of the flash Jay Garrick from
basically like an alternate reality not
knowing it's an alternate reality for
him they're just stories but it's these
cool little nuances these cool little
things the discussion between himself
and Nora where barriers basically you
know he got into a fight because he was
helping some other kid out his mom says
whatever you do never lose that
of course it's it's these small cool
little things now following that you
basically get this sort of like crack of
lightning right this kind of ominous
thing and this is really Joshua
williamson's way of tying in to like
eobard thawne because that's one of the
big things that that a lot of people
would really be a stickler about right
like those individuals who really love
the mythos of Barry who don't want to
see things change that'd be one of those
things that would kind of get pissy
about it if like you know what if she
came along and said actually eobard
thawne never kill the kill the mother of
Barry because it's like it's a mainstay
of his character I did be like if Brian
Michael Bendis came along and so the
Krypton never actually blew up and like
Superman was just sent away from Krypton
because his parents are just curious
about like what was out there you know
what earth was or something along those
lines
it'd be arbitrarily changing something
that that would be like a lot of fans to
get upset now 24 25 years reading comics
I don't really get upset by change but
people who kind of latch onto characters
usually have a tendency to get upset
about things that like totally shift
away from what they know and love
because in a lot of ways these
characters kind of become part and
parcel to their identities because they
were reading them for so long which sort
of makes sense I mean I'm kind of like
that with the x-men but the x-men have
changed so much that doesn't really
matter that much anyway so it's
literally a comic book built on change
so it's kind of kind of wild and kind of
interesting but again these small little
things the first interaction between
Barry and iris West kind of tying into
the new 52 to a degree these small
little things that take place in terms
of these characters meeting for the
first time these characters kind of
coming in coming along August hard you
basically see him kind of thrown in and
it's like yes he was introduced as part
of a flash rebirth with regard to I
guess really williamson's run flash
rebirth in terms of becoming Godspeed
this is where a lot of this sorts out
that he and Barry go back when they were
both working or not working in CSI but
again you get these small little ominous
things a yellow crack of lightning the
actions of eobard thawne really kind of
hitting at the idea that he's out there
now one of the things that Williams did
kind of leaves out here and then he sort
of leaves it to us to begin to kind of
figure out is the action of Barry being
struck by lightning and hit with
chemicals at the same time gaining his
powers of the flash back during the
Silver Age when he first showed up in DC
showcase for and it was just kind of
like well this is thing that happened
and like now he's the flash and it
worked because it was really kind of
blending like science fiction themes
with superheroes and people loved it
like they they kind of took off with it
and that was basically the end of that
it wasn't until like Geoff Johns came
about and even when he started getting
getting into a few stories before him do
you started to get into this this notion
that like eobard thawne had set
everything up for Barry Allen to become
the flash in the first place and that's
why Geoff Johns Run is really considered
to be kind of one of the most notable
runs in terms of retelling the origin of
Barry because where previously it was
eobard thawne killed the mother of Barry
and that's why Barry but you know became
a superhero when he became the flash
what you ended up getting in Geoff Johns
run was eobard thawne traveled back into
the past in order to make sure that
Barry became the flash he engineered his
whole life it's because of eobard thawne
that Barry Allen's mom died and it was
because of eobard thawne that the
chemicals were arranged in the right
order so that when he was struck by
lightning and hit with those chemicals
he would become a flash eobard thawne
arranged all of that and that's one of
the things that waves and kind of leaves
out here he kind of removes from that
but in all reality he can probably get
away with that because for the most part
even if the details aren't widely known
by the glitter coming up a community
people know enough about the
reverse-flash to know that he's
basically the reason Barry became the
flash as it was kind of like throwing
that little tidbit in there now it could
be that Williamson will come along and
change that because again this is only
part one we still have you know several
other chapters left in this and so it
could be that Williamson will change all
that and kind of shift everything up in
its entirety I'm actually kind of
excited to find out but from here it
turns into Barry doing exactly what it
expects him to do what
to figure out how his powers work and
again this is kind of a homage to the
Silver Age it's the homage to like the
original berry stories this is what they
did whenever her super heroes were first
created back in the the 40s 50s 60s and
even the 70s and 80s to a degree what
you would basically get is like their
origin story and then like a display of
their powers and the display of their
abilities usually came by way of
experimenting and testing them so that
way the comic book writer could
literally tell you what they could do as
the as the character was figuring it out
and so it was Barry it's much the same
way
how fast can humor how fast can he run
off ask and he moved he kind of goes
through this whole process where he's
like okay instead of it just kind of
being a circumstance like you saw in the
Silver Age where circumstances would
Linda berry learning about a power right
like something would happen and then he
would realize to get phased through face
you solid matter instead he puts his
mind a task and says okay if I can move
super fast it means my whole body moves
super fast and if my whole body moves
super fast then that basically means my
molecules and my atoms do too so I
wonder if I can phase through stuff as
it was like over the course of a really
really short amount of time he literally
starts going through and realizes he can
read super fast he's got an idea
addicting memory which he kind of always
had to a degree he can phase through
solid matter I mean he can do all kinds
of crazy things with his powers now and
so again like he kind of takes
attachment says well then maybe we
should become a superhero he burns
through shoes he does all kinds of crazy
stuff and basically learns how his
powers work in a very short amount of
time so that's when he starts developing
like outfits they can basically work for
him so he starts developing the flash
boots that allow him to run without
tearing up the material small little
things like this kind of go into the
greater whole in terms of Barry learning
his powers and learning what he's
capable of now something that Williamson
sort of leaves out here is the Speed
Force and here's the reason why there's
really a couple explanations we can go
to in terms of why this seems to happen
one he hasn't gotten around to it yet
and or at least he has but we haven't
seen it in the story yet so it could be
in parts like two three four or five
something like that it could be that
like at the end of this whole thing max
mercury comes back and that's basically
like when max mercury returns are like
the origin story there's like okay max
mercury is here now Barry has to go find
him you know after this origin story's
done but whatever the case is like max
mercury is the one who explains the
nature of the Speed Force to be it could
simply just be that that he'll reveal it
you know that Williamson will reveal it
in some former fashion in a different
way or it could be that Williamson is
taking a page out of Geoff Johns run on
the flash and the Speed Force hasn't
existed yet it doesn't it doesn't exist
yet and I know it kind of runs into to a
weird quagmire
people will say how can Barry Allen's
happen to the speedforce if the Speed
Force doesn't exist well we've talked
about this before one of the things that
was kind of established by Geoff Johns
is that because the Speed Force was
created by Mark Waid and because the
Speed Force was such an intrinsic part
of the flash mythos the Geoff Johns
couldn't ride it out of existence what
he had to do was find a way to make it
work and so what he ended up saying was
that the Speed Force didn't exist until
Barry Allen became the flash and then
once he became the flash the more he ran
the more the Speed Force began to grow
and as the Speed Force crew it began to
permeate throughout all space and time
right so it's like filling up a jar with
you know water or something like that
what it basically means is that as the
Speed Force grows it begins to spread
into the both the future the present
I'm sorry into the future itself the
present and the past and so basically
what this means is that where Barry
Allen just became the flash he basically
just he tapped into a Speed Force that
doesn't exist yet because it'll
basically reach his point in the past
sometime in the future so I know it
becomes kind of weird and it gets kind
of kind of strange and crazy but it's a
nature the Speed Force in the nature of
comics it's really the only way to kind
of reconcile those things but that's
basically what it is is it Barry's tap
down tap into the Speed Force but the
Speed Force as strong as it is now
originates in the future so again it's
it's it's wild so imagine the Speed
Force just kind of time travels more or
less into the past just kind of spreads
throughout the past in the present but
it sees small little things these small
little tidbits that really kind of feed
into the greater whole and that's why
this story is so cool is because for
tried and true Barry Allen fans like for
real true Barry Allen flash fans they
will recognize all these things don't
realize all these things because they've
they've you know read the characters
they read the histories or whatever the
case may be
they're aware of like all these small
little nuances for the newer fans this
is new stuff these are things that you
know that are really kind of like tying
in and sort of expanding this mythos and
while they may not necessarily know what
it is it is kind of cool to the tub to
basically look it up and then see the
familiarity that goes into creating a
story like this and so the small little
little tidbit that we get is really
where like Barry Allen's running and
then he ends up running into the future
and when that happens he runs into two
things one is a future version of
himself who basically says time travels
bad we should stop doing it and then two
we basically get like king turtle now
king turtles are cool character is it's
not really keen turtle at this point in
the future it is but the reason why
eternals here is because there were
basically two versions of him back in
the day the first one was an all flash
number 24 or something like that it was
a villain of the original flash Jay
Garrick
and then in DC showcase number four it
was the first villain berry face-off
against a guy named turtle that's why
this is chosen is because it was
basically the first villain berry ever
faced off against now the circumstances
under which they're fighting each other
is different but it was still kind of a
cool little thing and it's just the
small little Easter eggs just sort of go
into this they kind of build up the
flash mythos tying in to the old stories
bringing them all back in and really is
it's one of these things where the more
things change the more they stay the
same it's a cool little segment I really
enjoy it but we that being said guys
we're gonna read this video to an end if
you are new here too comments explained
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
you